well now hold on now will your wife
be going out on the road with you well
let me let me explain this okay because
if this is really touch and go you know
she's not another best she ain't gonna
think best place
no but i don't want to do that you have
a new happy part of your life yeah
something yes what is that well you know
uh my bath passed over a year ago one
day i was praying and
i looked in genesis and lo and behold i
looked down and was reading it said
because i was trying to find out what
adam did to get eve
you know she's up there dancing with
angels and stuff and i'm down here
bawling every day
yeah and i read the bible said in the
old testament genesis
for god does not want a man to be alone
and so i started saying uh oh
if beth was left here and i went to
heaven
as long as it was a christian and he
owned an airplane
i would approve it so
uh my francie doesn't own an airplane
but she's a great christian
so god gave me a second chance
how did you know she was the right one
well
uh why she's when i asked her first date
i she said yeah if you'll go to church
so
i got in the church in the pew and tried
to grab her hand and she
shuck it off i thought okay round one
and then the worship service started you
know and she raised her hands and
started
praising the lord and i said mom look at
here
look mom and so i was crying because she
was crying the whole church was crying
and she came back and stood next to me i
grabbed her hand
she squeezed i said gotcha
really that's true so from there on it
just
you end up you get engaged what was that
like and when did you know
that you wanted to get engaged well i'm
older guy bro you know one of my days is
like
45 or 50 of yours so i knew
right away i'd been in love right and i
knew right away that
this was love and of course i moved fast
right
like you do and uh i knew that i didn't
have to go any farther so
i'd never heard of getting down on one
knee
and uh she made me do that you know and
i
i kneel for the cross and stand for the
flag and she's like
you know so i knelt down and said
francie would you marry me and she said
yes
we'll pick a date later how do you you
have
your new fiance and you love her but at
the same time you still
think of beth and you honor her how did
you honor her this year
well after it was a while back but a
year ago
have her passing you know biblically
there's a lot of things that
something happens right so every
father's day
usually we would fly from hawaii to
colorado and she would go down the
platte river on the
on a tube and she would love it right
and so
this time i sent the tube it
sent her off and francie was there my
kids were there and
and then i you know i google almost
everything anymore my new
college education and uh it said that
to do that once a year so we all said on
this date
june 26 we'll do that and uh francie has
a date
december 30th he left right after
christmas
so we honor those dates and we you know
we
don't feel guilty but it's kind of
strange but
you know we're in love and we just
i know i say all the time beth i'm glad
you provided me with the francie because
that wasn't on my list
yeah and so i'm sure bob francie's
ex-husband she never heard him say a
swear word
and i says oh my god wait till she gets
a load of me
will your wife be going out on the road
with you well
let me let me explain this okay because
if this is really touch-and-go you know
she's not another best she ain't gonna
take best place no but i don't want to
do that
i took her out to take notes in west
virginia yes
i wanted to see what he did and i've
never
i hadn't watched the show and
i didn't want to because i wanted to
know him i didn't want i didn't know who
he was already
but i didn't watch because i wanted to
know him for
him and that's how i see him this is
dwayne lee chapman
to me not dog right so
i wanted to go and see what he was doing
and i had no intentions of us even
talking about
me helping him um and then we went to
virginia
and we open the line brah bra call dog
you want to tell me about your criminals
that you're looking for that hurts your
baby that hurts you
listen bro call dog bra
call dog right she start answering the
phone
all of a sudden i saw the compassion
i saw the compassion wait a minute i'm
like
i saw the love of my people
wait a minute and then i took her out to
take
notes and she's like honey watch that
guy on the right side
so she was in it oh my god and she's
dwayne dwayne twain you see that is that
him right there
oh i looked right by the guy i was like
oh my god
his most wanted west virginia brother
and uh what was he a child snatcher
he was there was sex trafficking charges
and charges for methamphetamines cooking
methamphetamines and distribution
and he had jumped bail and they were
they caught they asked him to come and
see if he was still in that town if he
could flush him out
not really to do a bounty and so i
thought okay well this is
will be a good time for me to see what
you do a little bit how many days
three days i am 72 hours called dog
and i can understand you know um dwayne
and beth built a legacy
with the shows and she has in her own
right outside of dwayne
thousands of fans went people that
genuinely
love her so i do understand
the um how could you do this so quickly
and this wasn't anything that either one
of us
i don't i haven't had to really
uh answer to that because i don't live
my life
in the public eye right and i'm
seven months ahead of was seven months
ahead of
duane losing bob and it's not
we didn't expect this either and
i told everyone in my life in my family
my son thought i was going to run off
and be a missionary in africa just
not to deal with life without bob
anymore
so either one of us really were
expecting what happened but we know that
god brought us together
and there's no way we would have met
each other
and how it all fell into place
um was a miracle she was going to be
a missionary the truth yeah i said
francie
let me take it he's going to buy it
i said listen i do this for living honey
let me take you on a mission she's like
all right
no she really was gonna do that i was
wow and um
i i don't doubt one for one second
bob wrote me a whole bunch of letters
and left them for me
after i found them after he went home oh
wow
and i know what he wanted for my life i
will know what he wanted for me to do
after he went home and
the fact that god dropped this
amazing guy right next to me to
walk alongside me and be my friend and
have this amazing relationship that
we're building
is a miracle